gente bom dia
eu acho que muitas pessoas quando verão
esse tema meditação ambientes de alta
performance já começaram a pensar nossa
agora que eu vou produzir mais no meu
trabalho vou vender mais
vou realizar mais coisas no meu trabalho
bom eu gostaria de lembrar que o mais
importante ambiente de alta performance
é a sua vida é na vida que nós
precisamos pensar em ser melhores
melhores seres humanos pais mães e para
isso nós temos que lembrar que a vida
ela é cheia de elementos interessantes
família amigos fazer um trabalho
voluntário levar alegria para as pessoas
se divertirem se divertir pra valer
focar em treinar alguma habilidade
específica pela qual você tem afinidade
quem sabe meditar um pouco para tentar
encontrar quais são esses talentos e
claro procurar conhecer encontrar muitas
pessoas pessoas muito interessantes
dentro dessa visão eu quero diz contra
desconstruir um pouco essa idéia de alta
performance né porque quando a gente
pensa no ambiente de alta performance
logo vêm aquelas idéias vamos ter
melhores resultados melhor utilização de
recursos aumento de receita segurança
engajamento qualidade maior
produtividade
só de ver essas palavras a gente já
começa a ficar estressado no ar e eu
gostaria de fazer com que todos nós
pensássemos que alto nível de stress
talvez não possa nos levar a uma alta
performance
existe uma curva clássica entre estresse
performance não é que está representada
aqui
o que eu percebo que se meu stress ou
estimulação é baixo
a minha performance é baixa então pouco
estresse também não é bom
à medida que o aumento um pouquinho meu
stress a minha simulação eu vou
aumentando meu interesse é a minha
atenção ea má performance vai aumentando
aumento stress aumenta a performance até
que chegou um ponto ótimo de stress
e uma ótima performance e como é que eu
conheço isso eu só vou conhecer isso me
conhecendo
conhecendo os meus limites conhecendo as
minhas características
aí eu vou conseguir encontrar com este
ponto de estimulação estresse para ter
alta performance
porque se eu passar disso se eu começar
a aumentar muito meu stress e se percebe
que a performance está caindo e caindo
talvez eu entrei aqui em depressão e
bernal ti
em outras palavras alta performance não
é sinônimo de alto nível de stress
então para isso nós temos que entender
que o stress pode ser de dois tipos
básicos pois são esses dois tipos
básicos de stress o mal stress nem
aquilo que geralmente a gente se
relaciona com a palavra stress
reconhecida como distress que me levam
sofrimento mas existe ainda o eustress
que o stress positivo aquele que vai me
levar à alta performance no meu dia a
dia nos nas mais diferentes áreas da
minha vida
o dis 3 representado aqui né eu acho que
todos nós nos sentimos em algum momento
dessa forma ele rs
ele se refere a longos períodos de
stress quando nós não nos conseguimos
adaptar a uma situação quando nós
perdemos o controle podendo nos levar a
doenças físicas e mentais e problemas
cardíacos e hipertensão obesidade
podemos ter também transtornos mentais
como ansiedade e depressão
agora quando eu compreendo que pode
haver um stress bombom stress ou stress
eu sinto que eu posso realizar coisas
porque esse estresse ele tem um começo
meio enfim eu sei disso então tenho uma
resposta positiva ao stress
eu sinto uma satisfação pela vida
esperança significado e bem estar
em outras palavras eu gostaria de
lembrar de um elemento muito importante
para a alta performance que é um alto
nível de bem estar
então alta performance igual algum nível
de estresse e um alto nível de bem-estar
então
temos que buscar esse bem estar das
nossas vidas e parece que as coisas não
estão indo nesse sentido no mundo né
nessa página do fórum econômico mundial
é um grande o número crescente de
pessoas está sentindo que o seu trabalho
é inútil sem sentido
será que alguém está se sentindo assim
numa pesquisa da harvard business review
de 2013
olha só metade das pessoas acho que o
seu trabalho não tem significado não tem
sentido você já pensou ficar oito horas
no mínimo do seu dia fazendo uma coisa
que você acha que não tem sentido
nesse outro estudo só 13% das pessoas
diziam que estavam gostando do seu
trabalho que talvez seja aquilo que
ocupe mais tempo da sua vida por uma uma
fase aí que leve 35 ou mais anos no caso
do brasil é a partir de agora bom e 30
por cento dos britânicos uma outra
pesquisa considerava o seu trabalho e
inútil é uma palavra forte né dói até lá
vem a gente pensar em quem está
trabalhando e sofrendo porque senti que
aquilo não tem sentido
então como controlar o stress e aumentar
o bem estar
essa é a grande é o grande x dessa
questão é dessa apresentação uma das
ferramentas pode ser a meditação eu não
descarto outras ferramentas como
psicoterapia né
como por exemplo fazer um processo de
análise
tá mas a meditação é uma ferramenta
impossível e disponível e muitas pessoas
têm se interessado nessa ferramenta da
meditação no sentido de tentar sair do
piloto automático
né conseguir ver o que realmente importa
na sua vida que faz sentido nesse livro
do famoso daniel goleman né
daniel goleman dos grandes propagadores
da ideia da inteligência emocional neste
novo livro do goldman chamado foco né
ele traz a prática de meditação como uma
das possíveis saídas para essa nossa
distração que está é que após que uma
epidemia diz trás
o que nós sofremos na nossa sociedade
por exemplo as crianças e os seus
aparelhos tem criança que fica quase que
mais tempo é ligado ao seu tablet o seu
joguinho do que convivendo com pessoas
as apresentações têm ficado mais curtas
está ali o cronômetro e avisando que eu
só tenho 11 minutos pra falar pra vocês
a mente pode se distrair 40% do tempo de
leitura
já para pensar o que é isso se distrair
e 40 por cento do seu tempo ea distração
pode ter uma implicação muito séria na
sua vida a gente ficar só no mundo das
idéias devaneando não necessariamente é
bom pelo menos nesse estudo na science
publicada em 2010 né
nós chegamos à conclusão de que uma
mente que devaneia é uma mente infeliz
basicamente eles fizeram uma pesquisa
através de um aplicativo e quando as
pessoas respondiam um baixo nível de
felicidade né
esse baixo índice de felicidade estava
associado dentre outros elementos aos
momentos em que a pessoa estava
devaneando né
quando a gente de vaney a gente entra no
mundo das preocupações não é isso
tá e conseqüentemente nós não nos
sentimos felizes meditar pode nos ajudar
a trazer a nossa mente para o momento
presente pro aqui agora sair desses
estados de devaneio e fazer com que a
gente passa a prestar mais atenção nos
nossos eventos diários e com isso passar
a sair do que a gente chama de
automatismo né
quantas coisas a gente faz o dia decidiu
simplesmente forma automática sem
realmente ter consciência do que está
acontecendo nesse estudo por exemplo que
nós publicamos sim na neuroimage né
nós comparamos indivíduos que não
editavam com indivíduos que meditavam
com regularidade há pelo menos três anos
e o resultado foi o seguinte durante uma
tarefa de atenção quem não acreditava
tinha que ativar essas áreas a mais e
amarelo no cérebro né do que pessoas que
meditavam com regularidade
então quem não acreditava parece que
tinha que fazer mais esforço
isso para manter a atenção do que quem
meditava regularmente e esse estudo
ficou como mais baixado desta que é uma
das revistas mais importantes da área de
neuroimagem por quatro meses
essas idéias de atenção e tudo mais tem
tomado tanto vulto né que grandes
companhias como a google começaram a
criar seus próprios programas de
meditação como esse por exemplo criado
pelo engenheiro chave nem tanque chamado
surge inside your self o inesperado
caminho para alcançar o sucesso a
felicidade ea paz mundial e realmente o
chade ele tem essa
essa paixão por tentar fazer com que as
pessoas possam viver melhor
o objetivo por dele ter criado esse
programa de meditação dentro da google
foi fazer com que as pessoas comecem a
entender o quão importante é a
inteligência emocional
a forma como eu vou me relacionar com as
pessoas me relacionar né com os meus
subordinados dentro da empresa assim
como os diretores da empresa né
além de desenvolver também um outro
componente que a compaixão
dentro da visão do chade a compaixão é
um elemento fundamental para os
principais líderes porque ele te permite
sair da sua posição e go estica e
começar a compreender não só o outro mas
a organização e as necessidades da
organização como um todo nós temos aqui
um outro grande executivo que auxiliou o
do linkedin é o chef wiener
eles vêm alguns anos falando e
propagando a idéia do gerenciamento com
passivo através do momento através da
compaixão eu sou capaz então de parar
sentar na frente das pessoas olhar nos
olhos delas e realmente tentar entender
com profundidade essas pessoas que estão
convivendo comigo e essa ideia de
liderança compassiva não se encaixa
apenas no ambiente de trabalho é no seu
dia a dia como ser um bom pai uma boa
mãe um bom amigo né é como eu posso
criar um trabalho voluntário que se
propague e sempre e uma frase do howard
gardner o pai da teoria das
inteligências múltiplas
de acordo com esta visão das
inteligências múltiplas não existe uma
excelência profissional
se você não tiver comprometimento e
ética
nós não estamos simplesmente falando de
ganhar dinheiro
vocês estão vendo vários casos aí de
corrupção né sendo revelados onde o
objetivo foi ganhar dinheiro
dentro dessa visão do howard gardner
liderança não é só isso exceção com um
componente que tem que ser permeado por
muitos valores né humanos
a compaixão e à ética e à meditação dele
nesse sentido ela pode nos ajudar a
desenvolver atenção e consciência foco
sem foco nós não atingimos nossos
objetivos sejam eles profissionais ou
pessoais
então atenção e foco esse foco e atenção
também nos ajuda a regular as nossas
emoções a desenvolver um sentido mais
compassivo a viabilidade de colocar no
lugar do outro e ver que o outro está
sofrendo também assim como eu posso
estar em sofrimento e através disso
retroalimentar o senso de ética
a ética é a base em todas as as
tradições que deram origem às práticas
meditativas né
não importa se em duisburgo disso o
cristianismo a ética está na base dessas
tradições onde existem práticas do tipo
meditativas e só assim é que a gente
pode pensar em uma alta performance de
verdade né
é nesse sentido que eu quero falar para
vocês sobre a alta performance
vamos pensar sobre isso no nosso dia a
dia não apenas no nosso trabalho e aqui
eu trago um
uma frase de um indivíduo que certamente
sabe o que a alta performance o kelly
slater mais do que eu sou fã
ele foi 11 vezes campeão mundial de
surfe né
por sinal também um esporte que eu adoro
né
uma atividade que eu adoro motivação é
temporária inspiração é permanente e
para nos mantermos inspirados nós temos
que ter essa habilidade de parar olhar
pra dentro e sentir o que realmente
importa para a nossa mente e para o
nosso coração obrigado
[Aplausos]